'pour l'état madame laure de la raudière
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
ma question porte sur le retard pris par
la france pour la couverture en très
haut débit de son territoire alors qu'en
2012 notre pays était en avance sur ses
partenaires européens
elle se classe aujourd'hui en 26e
position derrière l'angleterre
l'allemagne ou l'espagne
sur ce sujet aussi mes chers collègues
la france décroche
d'un côté on se glorifie du succès de la
french tech au consumer electronic show
de las vegas et de l'autre on laisse
crever nos territoires ruraux
aujourd'hui seulement 30 % des
habitations des zones rurales
seulement 30% des habitations des zones
rurales ont accès au très haut débit
compte plus de 65% en ville mais croyez
vous vraiment qu'un collégien ou un
homme à nice et un habitant à la
campagne n'a pas les mêmes besoins
d'accès à la formidable base de
connaissances qui internet qu'un
collégien ou un lycée un des vilains
croyez vous qu'une petite entreprise
industrielle ou un entrepreneur du pech
n'a pas le besoin les mêmes besoins
qu'un entrepreneur de banlieue croyez
vous que les agriculteurs puissent se
passer du numérique et de la révolution
les objets connectés pour rendre leur
exploitation plus compétitive et croyez
vous que nous puissions nous passer du
développement de la télémédecine dans
nos territoires ruraux
alors que vous les avez laissé devenir
des déserts médicaux
alors que faites vous des habitants des
zones rurales n'en peuvent plus d'être
les oubliés de la politique numérique de
ce gouvernement
heureusement certaines collectivités
locales prennent le relais mais vous les
avez étrangler financièrement avec la
baisse des dotations l'argent prévu sur
le plan très haut débit va manquer en
2017 pour financer l'ensemble des
projets et rien n'a été fait monsieur le
ministre on a l'impression que vous avez
baissé les bras
c'est pourtant l'une des trois attendent
priorité de la ruralité avait prévu de
remercie la parole est à madame axel
r secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
et de l'innovation et mes chers
collègues
si vous avez beaucoup des changes à voir
les uns avec les autres je vous propose
de les avoir dans les salles attenantes
mais c'est très désagréable pour les
intervenants d'avoir ce bruit de fond a
lésé merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
madame la députée laure de la raudière
vous avez cité un pays le royaume uni
que je connais bien qui a annoncé
récemment
l'ambition de ce plan de couverte son
plan de couverture numérique du
territoire national à hauteur de 400
millions de livres sterling s'est
finalement pas tellement loin de du
niveau d'ambition que nous avons trouvé
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en 2012
puisque le plan du gouvernement
précédent s'élevait à 900 millions
d'euros
eh bien avec le lancement du plan france
très haut débit qui vise à couvrir en
priorité les zones rurales et toutes les
zones rurales de notre pays ce sont 3,3
milliards d'euros que nous avons investi
dans les campagnes de france alors oui
effectivement si on se fie aux études
européennes statique et non pas
dynamique on peut considérer sur un mode
polémique qui ne ressemble pas à ce
sujet qui pourtant d'habitude fait
consensus et nous réunissons c'est bon
on peut considérer que la france a du
retard mais il se trouve que moi et mon
gouvernement
on regarde demain en se en ce sens
s'inscrit dans l'avenir
le plan france très haut débit l'eau il
couvrira 100 % de la population
française est 100 % des entreprises en
très haut débit d'ici 2022 et en 2022
grâce au niveau d'investissement de
l'état mais aussi des collectivités
locales de toutes les collectivités et
ce sont 100 % des départements qui sont
engagés dans le plan france très haut
débit à nos côtés et aux côtés de la
commission européenne pour financer ce
plan très ambitieux et bien c'est tout
un pays qui
à couvert et kiwi fera partie des pays
les mieux couverts du monde est très
certainement en tête des pays européens
dans cet horizon de cinq ans merci la
parole et tamada